[inaudible]
if you want to win so bad,
what I need to be worried
about is the team winning.
Stop sitting around making
excuses and take action.
[inaudible]
what's your team and you put your mission
above yourself and above your ego.
You will win. Nothing's
going to get in my way.
This isn't about data anymore. You're
moving into real life. If they get it,
you've done it right. If they don't
get it, you haven't done it right.
The a situation, make a decision
and do something about it.
You need to be at winter patches on.
Don't always just think about
that immediate short term measure.
Think about this strategic mission
as well. I know it sounds simple.
It's not easy. Even though it's
hard work. We had fun. Why?
Because it's fun to win. What
do you preach to other people,
but actually hold the rate from
yourself. Who in here made it
great decision when they were
emotional? Raise your hand.
Yeah, that's right. And problems.
They only get worse if
you don't address them.
They're not responding the way they
should. It's not them. It's you.
What do you call it? From the
sidelines in life? Absolutely nothing.
No excuses, no feeling sorry for yourself.
Just me checking your ego.
You can't self assess.
You can't improve default aggressive.
We were unstoppable on the battlefield.
You gotta to truly believe
that it's possible to win.
What leadership means to
me is winning at all costs.